we also live in circumstances where
people like Ahmadinejad who is a
fanatical Muslim has nuclear power is at
least aspiring towards getting one
Pakistan has one Egypt wants one turkey
wants one under those circumstances if
they succeed in acquiring these weapons
of mass destruction then we are facing
we're facing terrible times meaning if
you look at the Western evolution
towards modernity and the progress that
we have reached now those weapons were
not there there were mass murders they
were genocides there were lots of you
know all the atrocities that human
beings do to each other but having
nuclear weapons just makes things so
much more more dramatic and you know
it's not it's not easy times that's a
very pessimistic and what most urgent
thing that we need to look at now
another observation is if you look at
all the conflicts in the world today you
will be surprised by the number of
Muslims and tangled in conflicts among
themselves with China with pressure with
the West we are only one-fifth of the
world population having so many enemies
all at the same time it's very
self-destructive
now if the fanaticism within the Muslim
world that is now being fed by the fact
that if we die the hereafter is going to
be a better place then it's very
difficult to stop that but if that is
diluted and I always like to see the
carpets half-full that there will be
voices and that they will be strong
enough to say it's madness to commit to
kill and to be killed because of this
belief in the hereafter and make the
belief in the hereafter relative and
then things could look better but on the
very short time it looks
like things will look bad I think for
for people to understand it they should
probably see pictures of Hiroshima and
Nagasaki and that was pretty much a
primitive bomb the bombs that they are
trying to make now are far more advanced
and contain far more people and with
consequences for decades for the places
that are that will be affected that
someone like Mahmoud Ahmadinejad the
current president of Iran has made it
very clear that he is able he's willing
and he's able to acquire that bomb and
he's going to use it he has declared war
on the State of Israel when the leader
of one country tells the leader of
another country I'm going to wipe you
off the map that according to
international regulations is a
declaration of war
ever since he came to power he made it
very clear pretty much like Hitler when
he came to power that he was going in
that direction now the first reaction
was understandable where you see we
should negotiate this man let's
understand what he wants to say let's
talk to him let's use sanctions and so
on but you always have to have that
military option the option of force on
the table and my criticism on the
European Union leadership is that that
is off the table yes he has made it very
clear that he's going to use it and not
only that he is already financing and
disrupting the US policy and Western
policy in the Middle East and he's
trying to become very dominant in that
region and so he is someone who is very
much he's very self-assured because the
usual mode of determined you know
deterring someone from doing something
which are always material and worldly
things he doesn't believe him he
welcomes death and in that region it's
not yet I'm not saying that everyone
there believes that but part of the
radical Islamic doctrine is to believe
that things will be better in the
Hereafter so people welcome death not
all of them
many of them are those engaged in that
welcome death which means the old forms
of of deterring people from doing things
such as acquiring a bomb or using it
that the old methods the sanctions or so
on that's not something that's going to
make any impression on them